With SQLAlchemy, we can write
a single Python file to set up and
configure our database.
I will call this file database_setup.py.
Creating a database with SQLAlchemy
has four major coding components.
The configuration code, which is what we
use to import all the necessary modules.
The class code that we use to
represent our data in Python.
The table that represents
the specific table in our database.
And the mapper that connects the columns
of our table to the class that
represents it.
Our configuration code sets up all
of the dependencies needed for
my database and
binds my code to the SQLAlchemy engine.
For most cases, this code doesn't
change much from project to project.
We also have to create an instance
of a class called declarative base,
in order for our class to inherit
all the features of SQLAlchemy.
In addition, we need to add some
configuration code at the end of
our Python file to connect
to an existing database.
Or in this case, create a new one.
This might not make much
sense right now, so
let's jump into writing
the configuration code.
Open a text editor like Sublime and
follow along.
You may have seen this import if you've
worked on a few Python projects before.
The sys module provides a number of
functions and variables that can be
used to manipulate different parts
of the Python run-time environment.
Next, we're going to import the column.
ForeignKey, Integer, and
String classes from SQLAlchemy.
These will come in handy when
we are writing our mapper code.
>From the sqlalchemy.ext.declarative
library, we need to import our
declarative_base, which we will use
in the configuration and class code.
After that, we import relationship from
sqalchemy.orm in order to create our
foreign key relationships.
This, too, will be used when
we write up our mapper.
Let's also import
the create_engine class,
which we will use in our configuration
code at the end of the file.
This last piece of code isn't an import,
but
will help us get set up when we
begin to write our class code.
Let's make an instance of the
declarative_base class we just imported
and call it Base, for short.
The declarative_base will let
SQLAlchemy know that our classes
are special SQLAlchemy classes that
correspond to tables in our database.
At the end of our file,
we need to add two more lines of code.
We create an instance of
our create_engine class and
point to the database we will use.
Since we are using SQLite 3 for
this lesson, the create_engine will
create a new file that we can use
similarly to a more robust database
like MySQL or The last piece we need
is Base.metadata.create_all(engine),
which goes into the database and
adds the classes we will soon create
as new tables in our database.